Hey I was watching TV Eddie Murphy he  went on Jimmy show and did an impression  of you was [ __ ] awesome right did you  see that oh that's like Michael Jackson  writing a song just for you right also  well you should know much that put me in  a different lane with Eddie Murphy doing  the president of you it was damn good to  me  iconic great and I'm in coming to  America too  I am excited about this you are in the  movie with Eddie Murphy is that correct  um Rick Tom in the movie yeah yeah what  do you elect who are you in the movie  well Eddie had a son that he had a son  right and he came here the first one and  I'm that that boy's uncle oh you're the  uncle I'm his uncle and I said awesome I  always wanted to work with one of my  idol one of my idols got more my comedic  heroes and I got an opportunity to work  with him and we did on baby  cuz when this is all over y'all listen  that's gonna be the thing to do go see  coming to America  you